jussie Smollett is arrested for being
the perpetrator of his own race hate
crime a Coast Guard lieutenant is
arrested after pursuing a massive terror
plot and the world waits the Muller
report I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
oh man there is so much to get to today
we have all the updates on the jussie
Smollett case we have a fantastic update
on the so fresh so face AOC we now know
that she lives I kid you not in a luxury
apartment that does not have any
affordable housing in it
oh no why is this any shock it shouldn't
be a shock because Congress is gonna
Congress these folks they're not great
with they're not sending their best and
this is why I'm a big believer in
calling a convention of states where we
the people can propose amendments yes
amendments that could force for example
term limits on Congress and make them
balance the budget we've got to stop
these idiots before it is too late can
you imagine the look on the faces of
these Congress people when they realize
that millions of people are getting on
board and preparing to kick them out of
there forever offices that would be
pretty amazing it is time to remind
politicians that these offices belong to
the people and also that the budget
ought to be balanced you don't get to
live off the paychecks of the future
calling a convention of states is the
only way to get the job done
realistically they're already 3.8
million people with us on this more
every day know a lot of people worried
about a runaway convention that's not
how this works
a runaway convention only happens if the
left were to participate in the
convention of states that is not
something that is likely to occur
considering that it is pretty much all
people on the right are interested in
shoring up the Constitution against the
excesses of the left join me and my
friend Mark McClure go to convention of
states calm slash Ben to sign the
petition today that is convention of
states calm slash Ben go check it out
right now convention of states calm
slash Ben and sign the petition let's
get moving on this thing alrighty so the
breaking news this morning
Jesse Smollett the actor from Empire the
guy who told one of the most ridiculous
stories in the history of racial hoaxes
he has now been arrested sad trombone
for Jesse Smollett so Jesse Smollett you
will recall told his original tale and
people jumped on it it was a modern day
lynching according to both Kamala Harris
and Cory Booker it was something that
America had to apologize for according
to a bevy of Democrats including Speaker
of the House Nancy Pelosi and then every
Democrat sort of just disappeared as
soon as it turned out that jussie
Smollett was hoaxing the entire time if
there a smoke bomb and the on the floor
like Joe Bluth and then just ran away
and said illusion Michael it was pretty
amazing so Jesse Smollett has now been
arrested
the latest is that Jessie smell is
really bad at this so Jessie smell it
apparently a mediocre actor mediocre
daggered actor from from what we've
heard it turns out he's a better actor
than a writer so he is not going to get
his writer guild card any time soon
the only thing that he wrote properly
was the check to the people who were
actually supposed to commit the racial
hook since I kid you not
jussie Smollett personally wrote and
signed a check to the two men who then
carried out the fake racial beating
against Jesse Smollett the only thing
that he was missing was a for the hoax
notation in the in the what for line on
the check according to CBS local
accusing him of slapping the city in the
face Chicago police announced Thursday
that Empire actor jussie Smollett had
been charged with concocting an attack
in Streeterville because he was quote
dissatisfied with his salary
now that's fascinating in and of itself
that is really fascinating here's the
CPD Superintendent Eddie Johnson saying
this was all about Jesse smell that
trying to boost his own pay rate its
milette attempted to gain attention by
sending a false letter that relied on
racial homophobic and political language
when that didn't work well let paid
$3,500 to stage this attack and drag
Chicago's reputation through the mud in
the process and why this stunt was
orchestrated by Smollett because he was
dissatisfied with his salary so he
concocted a story about being attacked
notice the implicit the implicit truth
of Smollett rationale for the attack if
it turned out that he got away with it
if he was seen as a victim of a terrible
terrible hate crime hoax and that wasn't
a hoax if he'd been seen as a victim of
a hate crime if he had been able to get
away with claiming that two white men
found him on a Chicago Street shouted
racial and ethnic and and
stereotypically sexual orientation slurs
at him and then beat him roped him
around the neck threw bleach on him
while shouting this is nag a country
small its assumption was it would have
raised his salary in Hollywood you know
why he was making that assumption
because it's true it's the only part of
anything that small that did that is
true
it is absolutely true that if Jesse
Smollett had been seen as the victim of
a terrible terrible hate crime on the
mean streets of Chicago at to a
a polar vortex in which he still held on
to his Subway sandwich it is true that
his salary would have been increased he
would have gotten movie roles because
this is the way our society works if you
are seen to be a victim then you will
earn more money this is why all those
folks out there who say believe all
women or believe all victims or believe
all race crime but you can't believe all
anyone because there is in fact
incentive to lie in today's day and age
people keep saying well why would such
and such lie oh I don't know how about
for the increased salary how about the
fit for the fact that nobody had heard
of Jesse Smollett
unless you were a watcher of Empire
until like two weeks ago how about the
fact that Jesse Smollett appeared on
Good Morning America with Robin Roberts
where she presented him with fawning
treatment over a fake race crime there
is absolutely incentive in the United
States to fake this sort of stuff which
means that you need evidence before you
jump on the it certainly happened
bandwagon which is what the entire media
did and as I say the best part of this
is that Smollett actually personally
signed the $3,500 cheque also this just
demonstrates what President Trump has
said before which is that obviously the
immigrant the immigrant community is
undercutting the labor base in the
United States and obviously he hired two
Nigerian immigrants to perform this hate
crime hoax at $3,500 I mean imagine if
he'd had a higher domestic labor and
imagine if he'd actually gone all the
way and he had actually hired you know
white actors to carry this out obviously
you know this this just shows that
Jessie smell that was actually complicit
in the racist capitalist hierarchy of
the United States using his friends and
paying them less than market wage in
order to perform this race crime hoax
anyway Kathy the Chicago Police
Department superintendent he said he's
obviously pissed off and by the way
worth noting he's a black guy only
because we were talking about a race
hoax so this is not the Chicago PD
targeting Jesse smell it because they
are racist or because they are
homophobic here is the the Chicago
Police Department superintendent sang
Chicago has been painted in a negative
light
insinuate and to stage a hate crime of
that nature when he knew as a celebrity
that would get a lot of attention it's
just despicable you know
it's it makes you wonder what's going
through someone's mind to do something
like that so yeah I saw a couple of
parts of it and I was angered by it to
be quite honest yeah now what's
apparently taking a lot of people off
inside the Chicago Police Department is
that CPD is is treating him with kid
gloves even still so apparently one of
the spokespeople for the CPD a guy named
Guglielmo he said quote I know this can
be difficult emotionally and we hope he
doesn't do anything terrible we want to
make this as diplomatic as possible in
the end this is only a class 4 felony he
will get through this and we want to
make it as easy as possible for him to
do it but again it is about
accountability why do you want to make
it as easy as possible for justice mo
odd why would you want to make it easy
it should be hard for him because not
only did he stage a racial hoax that
captivated the entire nation not only
did he do that not only did he slander
the city of Chicago not only did he
slander Trump supporters not only did he
slander white people more generally but
he also was willing to send other people
to jail I mean this is a part of the
story people are missing if he had
carried this to its very end then Jesse
small that would have been testifying
falsely against two white people
arrested by the CPD imagine that the
Chicago PD had arrested two white people
who are in the area and Jesse smell that
had then gone and testified that those
people were the ones who beat him and
they'd went to jail for presumably 20
years right for a federal hate crime
imagine that had happened and he would
have been sitting there earning his
massive salary this guy is evil he is
evil unless you can point me to any
evidence that he is a mentally ill human
being this is an evil evil person
willing to do all of this for a few
pennies more on his salary by the way
I'm sure that this guy is in the top 1%
if he is appearing on every episode of
Empire that means that he is getting
royalties it means that he's probably
being paid upwards of 20 to 30 thousand
dollars in episode and yet here he is
trying to up his salary by presumably
trying to send other people to prison
falsely they should hit him with the
book I mean really they should put this
guy behind bars for as long as he can be
behind bars I know there are a lot of
people who are feeling sympathy for
justice Millette today I'm seeing it in
the media it's absurd it's absurd
the the Chicago Superintendent he said
bogus police reports cause real harm he
said my concern is that hate crimes will
now me publicly be met with a level of
skepticism that previously
didn't happen well every crime should be
met with the same level of skepticism
which has show me the evidence and if
there's no evidence of the crime then
we're gonna have to wait to see whether
evidence is finally made clear
disorderly conduct is a class 4 felony
that is what they're charging him with
only disorderly conduct which is
shocking to me apparently you can face
up to 1.5 years in prison or face
probation for something like this I am
shocked that he's not being charged with
more honestly 1.5 years in prison for
wasting presumably hundreds of thousands
of dollars in CPD time-wasting hundreds
of man-hours for really being ready to
bear false witness against people in
order to send them to jail it's absurd
it's it really is it's really disgusting
now just as disgusting as all of this is
the fact that they're still members of
the media who are trying to cover for
jussie Smollett I don't understand how
CNN can even pretend to be objective
well they have done lemon on this story
Don Lemon you'll recall he said openly
that he was texting with Jesse Smollett
in the middle of the story every single
day here is Don Lemon of CNN saying just
that about a week ago he has to deal
with discrimination as a black man then
on top of that he has to be gay and he's
out and then Fame yes and fame is not
natural and so I knew everyone would be
picking apart his stories not for me
that's not my concern
right that's right so every day I said
no you think I'm annoying I can show you
the text I know you think I'm annoying
you but I just okay that you're okay
yeah you need somebody you can talk to
me because there's not a lot of us
sometimes he responds he does he doesn't
respond it says you are not annoying
what a hero
Don Lemon what a hero and that's what
journalism is all about isn't it
reaching out to people who participate
in race crime hoax and in in hate crime
hoaxes reaching out to them personally
making sure they're okay instead of
asking questions Don's down lemon is in
this business we used to call it
journalism and in journalism when you
see an accountant that does not hold
water for more than 30 seconds you're
supposed to be asking questions but Don
Lemon says listen I'm not going to ask
any of those questions because he is a
black gay man and I am also a black gay
man so I know a black gay men in the
United States go through and that means
I was just reaching out to make sure he
okay I was gonna ask him a single
question I was gonna ask him like so
2:00 a.m. on a Chicago Street magnet
country really wasn't gonna ask that no
I was reaching out to him because why it
fit the narrative wait till you hear
what Don Lemon had to say last night as
Jesse small app was preparing for his
own arrest wait until you hear that
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the sheets upon
which you sleep we are never going to
agree on everything but we can all agree
that we could all use more sleep getting
a great tonight great night's sleep is
easier and more affordable than you
think you don't need a new expensive
mattress or sleeping pills you need to
change your sheets that's why you should
check out bowl and branch everything
bull and branch makes from bedding to
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cod and that means they start out super
soft they get even softer over time you
could buy it directly from them so
you're essentially paying wholesale
prices luxury sheets can cost up to like
$1,000 in the store bull and branch
sheets are only a couple of hundred
bucks everyone who tries Boleyn branch
sheets loves them which is why they have
thousands of five-star reviews I love my
bowl and bran sheets so much that my
wife and I actually tossed out all of
our other sheets that's how good they
are even three u.s. presidents sleep on
bull and branch sheets shipping is free
you can try them for 30 nights if you
don't love them send them back for a
refund but you're not gonna want to send
them back they are that comfortable to
get you started right now my listeners
getting 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets at bull and branch calm promo
code Ben go to bull and branch come
today for 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets that is bull and branch Bo LL and
branch calm promo code Ben go check it
out bull and branch calm promo code Ben
so Don Lemon very very objective CNN
reporter super duper objective not like
Sean Hannity doesn't pretend that he is
he doesn't say that he is an opinion
journalist he says he is an objective
reporter and he is so good at the
objective reporting that he never asked
jussie Smollett a single question
because as a black a man black gay men
who claim that they're victims of
obvious hoaxes we shouldn't ask them
questions so last night Don Lemon goes
on TV and he's still trying to defend
he's still trying to defend justice
Millette I mean it really is amazing
so he says it's not just his fault he
lost in the court of public opinion
seriously this is what Don Lemon is
saying on primetime CNN it's insane in
the court of public opinion jesse has
lost he's lost the fight in the court of
public opinion and that's where his
battle is
legally if he has to go whatever used to
serve if it's jail time if he has to do
probation if he has to pay whatever but
in the court of public opinion it
matters it matters and he lost that
because of how and not his fault maybe
people were I don't know what they were
saying to him how maybe because of his
representatives who knows I don't know
it was handled poorly oh that was the
problem it was handled poorly not that
he lied to the entire nation including
the Chicago Police Department about
being beaten on a Chicago Street in the
middle of the night by two white men
wearing mega caps I mean this is insane
journalism in everywhere so much
journalism 'ok my goodness explosive
journalism from from Don Lemon that guy
is a journalist I mean that's some
serious journalism he didn't just say
that he said that his real concern is
that conservatives are gonna eat Jesse's
lunch so I guess we're no longer worried
about a lynch mob now we are worried
about a lunch mob so here is Don Lemon
on CNN worried about the lunch mob that
is going to eat Jesse's lunch I mean
frankly jesse is gonna be served prison
commissary foods I don't think anybody
wants his lunch but here is Don Lemon
this is playing out every single moment
in cable news Sean Hannity is gonna eat
just a small let's lunch every single
second Tucker Carlson is gonna eat just
a small that's lunch every single second
risin it up the President of the United
States is gonna eat as lunch and who
does the president the United States
watch every night you evil news well
cable news okay cable moves gonna eat
him up that's the real problem here the
problem is not that he hoaxed America
the problem is not that he lied about a
huge swath of people
president Trump just tweeted out a few
minutes ago Jesse smile ahead what about
mega and the tens of millions of Bieber
you insulted with your racist and
dangerous comments hashtag mega and the
president is not wrong about this the
president now look should the president
be interjecting on these sorts of issues
no the president should not be
introducting on these issues any more
than President Obama should have been
interjecting on Trayvon Martin or
Michael Brown but Trump is not wrong on
the actual substance of his comments
which is that this was a massive slander
against at least half the country and
not only that it was Jesse smell that
attempting to rip open racial scabs
ripped them off in order so that he
could benefit himself and so that he
could push a narrative that his abs
lutely untrue and down lemons main
concern is that people are gonna be mean
to Jesse Smollett oh wow what a rough
life Jesse Smollett has and had again if
you want to show me evidence the guys
mentally oh then we can talk about
sympathy for Jesse Smollett unless you
have any evidence he's mentally ill then
he is a piece of human debris he is
filth he is filth you racially hoaxes
like this and by the way it is true that
you just that you end up degrading the
the accounts of other hate crime
survivors and degrading the other
stories of crime victims you end up
denigrating the Chicago Police
Department who are attempting to do
their best in a city rife with crime and
you are willing to testify to send other
people who are innocent to jail yeah my
sympathy level runs a little low for
Jesse small and not done lemons though
not done lemons he says that his big
concern here is that black and gay
people are most affected by the hoax of
course because Don Lemon is an
intersectional leftist that is all Don
Lemon cares about he's not a journalist
he's an intersectional opinion leftist
on CNN and he is portrayed as an
objective journalist and then the entire
media goes nuts when CNN hires a
partisan Republican as one of their
political editors one of their many
political editors yes because CNN is a
bastion of objectivity with Chris Cuomo
Andrew Cuomo's brother and Zhaan lemon
on every night just spewing leftist
nonsense here is Don Lemon doing just
that last night to certain groups of
people even if they were skeptical they
were like they said I hope this is not
true black folks gay folks people oh my
god no and you know why black folks gay
folks say that because there are real
victims of well because there are real
victims of homophobia and of racism but
also because unfortunately we tend to
all be painted with the same brush when
one person does wrong and that's why we
always say that when something goes
wrong as we hope the person is not black
we hope the person is not gay yeah and
nobody is painting all black people or
gay people as hoaxers because Jesse
Smollett was a hoaxer nobody is doing
that and that this is you can see the
media already attempting to draw this
narrative so what they're going to do
they're already preparing to make the
exact same mistake you can see it
happening in real time because here's
what's gonna happen a month from now
somebody is going to do the same hoax
somebody's going to do a ver
similar hoaxes maybe not as egregiously
botched as this one maybe not as stupid
as this one maybe he's not gonna hire
his personal trainers from the gym for
$3500 in a personalized check to go down
to the local hardware store purchase
some rope bleach and red hats and then
go out in Chicago at 2:00 a.m. and
claimed they're in Magda country maybe
they're not gonna do that but there will
be somebody else who makes a false claim
and then when people on the right say
listen you know evidence that might be
like a good thing then the left will say
the only reason you're asking for
evidence right now is because you're
racist it's because you look at Jessie
smell that's case and now you say that
all black people are all gay people are
hoaxing and then maybe that one turns
out to be a hoax and the media say well
you know the real problem here the real
problem here is that now everyone's
gonna paint all future hate crime
victims with the same brush and then it
sets it up for the next race crime
hoaxer the media are learning exactly
the reverse of the lesson they ought to
be learning from this the lesson they
ought to be learning from this is hey
maybe we should have waited for evidence
on the justice Millette thing instead of
just jumping on it with both feet and
suggesting that it was inherently
believable because we wanted to believe
it that's what happened here the media
jumped on this because the story was too
good to check and so they didn't check
this was a pure example of confirmation
bias and now the media are saying well
you know what could happen you know the
real problem with the jussie Smollett
hoax is not us wasn't us
jumping the gun the real problem is that
in the future people may now ask for
more evidence and that would be them
applying racism because if they ask for
more evidence the only reason they do
that is because they think that all
black and gay people are just like Jesse
Smollett so next time there's a hoaxer
who does the exact same thing or
something similar people will ask for
evidence Don Lemon will call them racist
for asking for evidence it will come out
that it was a hoax and then Don Lemon
will say well next time if you ask for
evidence you're only doing that because
you're racist it's it's it's so circular
and so self-defeating and so bad for the
country and members the media I'm not
even sure they know they're doing this
legitimately I don't even know that they
are that they believe they're doing this
they believe they are being sympathetic
but they're actually doing it setting
themselves up for another fall because
if you think the media learned a damn
thing from this you are dead wrong the
media did not learn one thing from this
no one in the media
no one is turning around and saying hey
you know what jump the gun it's because
I wanted to believe that it was true and
so I completely botched this one instead
you're getting all
the Democratic 2020 candidates stealth
deleting their own stuff they're just
going back and stealth deleting their
comments or leaving them up without any
of further comment you're seeing
Democratic candidates come out and say
you know what guys I need to wait for
more information okay so you didn't need
to wait for more information when it was
a sketchy account that was being
reported by third hand sources but you
do need to wait for more information
after there is a formal legal arrest of
jussie Smollett that's when you need to
wait for more information on real I
noticed by the way they're not seeing
the same let's wait for information take
on this Coast Guard lieutenant story
who's arrested in a terror plot we're
gonna get to that in just one second by
the way we shouldn't wait for more
information the guy's been arrested when
you get to that in just one second first
let's talk about losing your hair losing
your hair sucks you don't realize how
much you care about it until you start
losing it I know because male pattern
baldness runs in my family and so I have
a high value on my hair that's why you
should be using keeps the easiest and
most affordable way to keep the hair
that you have these FDA approved
products used to cost so much but now
thanks to keeps they are finally
inexpensive and easy to get for five
minutes now in just a buck a day you're
never gonna have to worry about hair
loss again getting started with keeps is
really easy sign up takes less than five
minutes just answer a few questions and
you snap some photos of your hair a
licensed physician will then review your
information online and recommend the
right treatment for you it is then
shipped right to your door every three
months keeps offers generic versions of
the only two fda-approved hair loss
products out there some of you probably
have tried them before but you've
probably never gotten them for this
price keeps his only ten bucks to 35
bucks a month
Plus right now you can get your first
month for free which is a hell of a deal
forgetting to keep your hair to receive
your first month of treatment for free
go to keeps calm /ban that is ke EPS
calm slash man that is a free month of
treatment at keeps calm slash men keeps
hair today hair tomorrow don't lose your
hair I mean go do something about it
keeps calm /ban ke EPS calm slash man
alright so you'll notice that the media
are not nearly as skeptical about the
the Coast Guard lieutenant who's
arrested yesterday you're not seeing the
20/20 candidates standing around going
you know we really ought to wait for
more information you know why because
you don't actually have to wait for more
information once somebody has been
arrested when somebody has been arrested
you can say we'll wait to see the
evidence in court but there's a pretty
good indicator that perhaps they did
something wrong at the very least we
have to take it a lot more seriously
than a random account by a human this
store
is truly awful according to the
Associated Press a Coast Guard
lieutenant who was arrested last week as
a domestic terrorist who drafted an
email discussing biological attacks and
had what appeared to be a hit list that
included prominent Democrats and media
figures prosecutor said in court papers
Christopher Paul Hassan is due to appear
Thursday in federal court in Maryland
after his arrest on gun and drug
offenses prosecutors say those charges
are the proverbial tip of the iceberg
prosecutors say the defendant is a
domestic terrorist bent on committing
acts dangerous to human life that are
intended to affect governmental conduct
apparently this piece of crap has
espoused extremist views for years and
what they mean by this is that he's an
actual neo-nazi court papers detail a
draft email in which he wrote that he
was dreaming of a way to kill almost
every last person on earth and pondering
how he might be able to acquire anthrax
and toxins to create botulism or a
deadly influenza so he sounds a delight
also he sounds he is a full-on neo-nazi
he sends himself a draft letter in
September 2017 that he had written to a
neo-nazi leader identifying himself as
white nationalist for over 30 years and
advocating for focused violence in order
to establish a white homeland apparently
he read portions of a manifesto by the
Norwegian mass murderer Anders Breivik
who is serving a 21 year sentence for
killing 77 people in a 2011 rampage by
the way just shows that Norway is a
crazy place a 21 year sentence for
killing 77 people is insane also this
this garbage human expressed admiration
for Russia he said looking to Russia
with hopeful eyes or any land that
despises the West's liberalism so he
sounds like a delight he searched the
internet for the most liberal senators
senators as well as searching two
senators have Secret Service protection
our Supreme Court justices protected his
list was all Democrats and media members
the only quasi Republican media member
on the list is Joe Scarborough of MSNBC
other prominent Democrats were Nancy
Pelosi Chuck Schumer Kirsten Gillibrand
Warren Booker Harris basically every
prominent Democrat in the country he
wanted to kill apparently he was a
chronic user of an opioid painkiller and
he was passing his drug test with the
Coast Guard by using fake urine so well
done government screening its own
employees once again showing how
competent everyone is but beyond that
but beyond that it is worthy of no
that there are insane people out there
and evil people forget insane because
there's no evidence the guy's actually
mentally ill as I say with Jesse
Smollett put this guy away throw away
the key
I will note that the media coverage of
this Coast Guard lieutenant has been
relatively muted so far the minute
there's an email expressing support for
president Trump watch it blow up now
that's exactly how this is going to work
meanwhile the other big news of the day
is that CNN is reporting that the molar
report is coming maybe as early as next
week according to CNN Attorney General
Bill Barr is preparing to announce as
early as next week
the completion of special counsel Robert
Muller's Russia investigation with plans
for bards to submit to Congress soon
after a summary of Muller's confidential
report according to people familiar with
the plans now we've been hearing this
for months but it has been widely
expected for a while that February was
going to be when this thing dropped the
preparations are the clearest indication
yet that Muller is nearly done with his
almost two-year investigation the
precise timing of the announcement is
indeed subject to change says CNN the
scope and contours of what bar will send
to Congress remain unclear also unclear
is how long it will take justice
officials to prepare what will be
submitted to lawmakers it is unclear at
this time how much of this will actually
be publicly released under the special
council regulations Muller has to submit
a confidential reports to the AG at the
conclusion of his work the rules do not
require it to be shared with Congress or
by extension the public as bars made
clear the Justice Department generally
guards against publicizing derogatory
information about uncharged individuals
so herein lies the legal challenge the
American public deserves to see as much
of this as possible because there are
too many rumors floating out there about
various members of the Trump
administration having cruded with Russia
and all the rest of this and that means
that putting the report out there as
publicly as possible would be good but
the DOJ also has an obligation not to
smear people without any intent to
charge criminally or without the basis
for a criminal charge president Trump
for his part he says the release of the
report is up to his attorney general
which is of course the correct answer
here's the president saying that
that'll be totally up to the new
Attorney General he's a tremendous man a
tremendous person who really respects
this country and respects the Justice
Department so that'll be totally up to
him now you can see the shifting
goalposts taking place on the Left
former Director of National Intelligence
James clapper who's been an ardent
advocate of the Russia collusion
Kwasi scandal he said on Wednesday and
he doesn't even know there's gonna be a
lot there in the report than when this
is all said and done the Mullen report
may be a giant disappointment is the
Robert Muller investigation enough to
tell if that's if that's the possible
scenario that you're looking at and you
think that what Andrew McCabe said is a
possible scenario is the Robert Muller
investigation and what's happening in
Congress enough I think that the hope is
that the mauler investigation will clear
the error on this issue once and for all
I'm really not sure a will and and the
investigation when completed could turn
out to be quite an anticlimactic and not
draw a conclusion about that man would
that give Democrats a sad I mean talk
about taking the wind out of their sails
but for two years of this and people
selling probably thousands of dollars in
robert muller gear keep calm and robert
muller and all the rest of us if it
turns out that the report is basically a
big nothing if the report turns out to
be basically a rehash of what we already
know with no criminal filings attached
or if it's not made public in the end
that's gonna be a big disappointment for
a lot of the folks in the Democratic
Party now that doesn't mean that all of
the problems surrounding President Trump
go away once the Moller report is
released next week Michael Cohen is set
to testify before the house according to
the New York Times Michael Cohen the
president's former personal fixer has
agreed to testify in public
next Wednesday before Congress about his
work lawmakers said they would limit the
scope of their questioning in deference
to the special counsel so they're only
going to ask him about his go-betweens
status for paying off for example
storming the annuals but they're not
going to ask him about Trump Russia
collusion matters the reason is they
don't want to step on Robert Muller's
toes and they also don't want to bias
people about what exactly was going on
in that investigation Muller has asked
that a lot of that material remain
confidential
the committee's chairman indicated that
after consultation with the DOJ and the
House Intelligence Committee Cohen would
not be a
to discuss matters related to Russia
including a proposed Trump tower project
in Moscow under scrutiny by the special
counsel robert muller now that is really
the big issue here it really is I mean I
think that the the greatest danger for
President Trump in terms of a criminal
indictment comes not from the Russia
stuff but from the New York district
attorneys who are going after him over
supposed campaign finance violations or
the state of New York going after the
Trump foundation for example that's
where most of his legal danger lies but
that is not where most of his public
relations danger lies if he ends up
being prosecuted for example over
campaign finance violations it's unclear
first of all that he can be prosecuted
while in office probably unlikely by DOJ
regulations but if people are talking
about campaign finance violations I
think President Trump survives that
pretty easily if they're talking about
Trump foundation stuff I don't think
anybody really cares I mean for better
or worse I think for worse I think
people don't care about this stuff
anymore if it's Russian collusion stuff
and they actually have proof then this
is a big issue and what what you can't
do is build up to one ending of the
movie and then switch over and into an
entirely different genre if you build up
to the end of an action movie and
suddenly it breaks into music and it's a
musical people are just confused so if
you've built up for three years that
Trump and Russia were in cahoots and
that Trump is a tool of Vladimir Putin
and then the ending of the movie is he
paid money to a pornstar nobody is gonna
buy that switch it just doesn't work
that way okay in just a second I want to
talk about why socialism seems to be
making gains in the United States and
why Democrats are not being forced to
answer for the crimes of Venezuela for
example at least democratic socialists
we'll get to all that in just a second
but first you need to go subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire com it comes with so many
goodies the $99 a year subscription is
even better because it's cheaper than
$9.99 a month I promise you do the math
you can do it yourself it is cheaper
also not only is it cheaper you get the
very best in beverage vessels the
leftist tiers hot or cold tongue tumbler
look how magnificent it is also what are
the other benefits you get why let me
tell you two additional hours of this
show every single day with great guest
our guest today Rafer Weigel from Fox 32
is the reporter who's been all over the
smollett story and representative Jim
Jordan from Ohio who will stop by to
tell us about the Muller report and
Michael Cohen and all the rest
also this Monday February 25th daily
wire backstage that's happening we'll be
talking about everyone's favorite award
show daily wire god-king Jeremy boring
me Andrew Clavin the execrable Michael
Mills and Julia Kraus will all be here
talking culture Hollywood and of course
taking your questions we will even be
wearing Oscar appropriate attire as
always only daily wire subscribers get
to ask those questions to make sure to
subscribe today also do not forget if
you're not a daily wire subscriber you
are really missing out because our next
Sunday special guest is the fantastic
larry elder your if your subscriber you
and only you can watch this episode a
full day early not only that all
upcoming episodes of the sunday special
will be available on saturday so it
becomes the saturday special just for
you don't worry guys I'm not violating
Sabbath that only works if you are a
daily wire subscriber what exactly are
you waiting for
I've just offered you a bevy of benefits
that you get how hard do I have to sell
this thing my goodness people go check
it out over at daily wire.com please
subscribe over at youtube and itunes as
well leave us a review we always
appreciate we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so one of the beautiful things about
being a Democratic Socialist is that you
don't actually have to live up to your
own ideals according to a lot of good
men over at the Washington Examiner
representative Alexander Ocasio Cortes
Democrat of New York fresh face of the
Democratic Party so much freshness so
much insane faceless she recently moved
into a luxury apartment complex in
Washington DC that does not offer the
affordable housing units that were a key
plank in the New York congresswoman's
campaign flatform
so sad here's the good news for
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez in 50 years
she'll have three houses and she'll be
running for president and she could win
I mean that's that's pretty much the
path to power for Democrats isn't it
you'd be useless for 50 years you live
off the fat of the land and then you run
as a full-on socialist and you have a
shot at the nomination
that's the Bernie Sanders way of doing
things and AOC looks to be following
that path again she can live whatever
she wants that's the beauty of America
but you don't get to criticize
developers for not building affordable
housing when you are living in the house
built by those developers that doesn't
have affordable housing Ocasio Court has
his new building built by leading DC
developer WC Smith as part of a luxury
complex whose owners specifically do not
offer affordable units under Washington
DC's affordable dwelling units program
isn't that sad that's so sad right I
mean I feel like she's kind of swampy oh
no apparently her new apartment complex
is magnificent it offers a hundred
thousand square feet of amenities for
its residents these include two private
massage rooms with state-of-the-art
hydrotherapy beds men's and women's
sounds a full-scale demonstration
kitchen with a woodfired pizza oven a 25
meter indoor lap pool a rooftop infinity
pool with panoramic views of the Capitol
a peloton cycling studio with over a
dozen bikes and a Fireside Lounge
featuring a Steinway & Sons player piano
also a PGA great golf simulation lounge
with wraparound screen and viewing bar
that allows residents to play virtually
at dozens of the world's most exclusive
golf courses with the touch of a button
this place sounds really nice for a
socialist apartments in the building
currently started about eighteen hundred
bucks per month for a 440 square foot
studio holy crap 1,800 bucks a month for
a 440 square foot studio what in the
living it that's like a bed
room 440 square foot studio for $1,800 a
month is it made of gold is it like is
it a Trump apartment it ranges up to
$5,200 for a three-bedroom get a
mortgage be smart with your money people
wow the average rent in Washington DC is
1,300 bucks from one bedroom apartment
and 1,550 bucks for a two-bedroom so
she's living the high life is Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez she's an American success
story from bartender to swanky luxury
apartment renting congresswoman in the
blink of an eye and all because we need
socialism we need socialism and this is
the beautiful thing about being a
socialist you never have to live up to
your own standards speaking of which
Bernard mix Anders the leading
Democratic contender in the race right
now
but nice embas he was asked specifically
about the situation in Venezuela where
it turns out 1,800 square-foot luxury
apartments with peloton cycling classes
and woodfired pizza ovens are not
available in Venezuela they have
wood-fired dog spits that's the thing
that's happening in Venezuela Bernie
Sanders who lives off the fat of the
American land while promoting democratic
socialism for everyone else he was asked
specifically about whether Nicolas
Maduro the socialist evil dictator or
Venezuela should go and here was his
answer you can see the one way though
the legitimate president of Venezuela I
think there are serious questions about
the recent elected there are many people
who feel it was fraudulent election and
I think the United States has got to
work with the international community to
make sure that there is a fair election
in Venezuela is Nicolas Maduro dictator
senator for you and should he go
I think clearly he has been very very
abusive that is a decision of the
Venezuelan people so I think Oh Jorge
there's got to be a free and fair
election oh so it's for Nicolas murder
I'm not gonna call him a dictator of
course that's not a shock because this
is the same guy who wouldn't call Daniel
Ortega a dictator and who said that the
USSR had wonderful youth programs so
socialism awesome for everyone except
the people who have vacation houses in
Vermont or luxury apartments in
Washington DC
well in just a second I'm gonna get to
what I think the real appeal of
socialism is because it's really kind of
fast
so there's an article by Jedediah
Britten Purdy over at the New Republic
and it's called the spiritual case for
socialism and this is the part where I
think people actually miss the appeal of
socialism so right now we live in a
world where the appeal of socialism is
income we've got to fight income
inequality there are too many poor
people and to any rich people and we
need to pick the rich people and cut off
their legs and feed them to the poor
people that is the only way to achieve
true equality in the United States and
around the world that's that sort of the
pitch for socialism and honestly not a
great pitch because the fact is that all
human prosperity over the last 200 years
all not some all human prosperity has
been driven by free markets and
volunteerism all of it now you may say
that redistribution piled atop the
capitalist superstructure has spread
that wealth around a little bit that
argument can be made I'm not sure that
it is the best argument because the fact
is the prosperity still exists in
nations that don't have these vast
social welfare networks because they
exist in the United States before there
were vast social welfare networks the
United States was the fastest growing
most powerful economy on planet earth
before the vast growth of the welfare
state under FDR but with all of that
said the fact is that free markets have
created all growth in the history of man
if you look at the per capita income of
human beings since 1800 it is basically
a straight line up it's not even it's
not even arithmetic its exponential
growth it's not linear its exponential
and that is because of capitalism and
free markets so it's hard to make the
case that the reason that we need
socialism is because we need more
prosperity because socialism is not
about prosperity what it is is it is a
spiritual it is an actual spiritual
phenomenon and that's what this article
at The New Republic says they talk about
a book by a person named Martin Hagelin
called this life secular faith and
spiritual freedom
Hagelin puts forward a single sustained
picture of the situation we all face
writes the columnist for The New
Republic to free ourselves spiritually
he proposes that we adopt what he calls
secular faith a commitment to our finite
lives and fragile loves as the sole
sight of what matters the setting for
all the stakes of existence achieving
material freedom is a more logistical II
complex project the only social order
compatible with spiritual freedom says
Hagelin is democratic socialism only
when return on investment ceases to be a
measure of value can the polity decide
itself what counts is valuable what kind
of activities should be rewarded and
cultivated in other words the idea here
is that there's an actual religious
faith that is Marxism that religious
faith suggests there is no afterlife
there is no higher spiritual meeting
there is only your material existence on
this plane and so we ought to maximize
your material existence on this plane
with a minimum of work that you don't
want to do so here is here's the basic
idea
basically this life this book attempts
to deepen the philosophical dimension
and to anchor its commitment commitments
in a larger inquiry what kind of
political and economic order can do
justice to our mortality so the fact
that all that our lives are all we have
the book suggests that we should discard
the religious impulse and we should just
we should separate the desire for
meaning and community from doctrine and
metaphysics so he rips on Christianity
he rips on faith he says that this faith
is bad what we really need is a brief
lifetime of perilous caring so this is
the socialist appeal the socialist
appeal is the idea that we can make
transformative decisions that free us
from the necessity of doing things other
people want socialism in and of itself
is actually a deeply narcissistic
philosophy capitalism is about the idea
that I can do what I feel is a value but
if my idea of value does not match your
idea of value I'm not gonna earn very
much money for it socialism is about the
idea that I should be able to do
whatever I want and you should pay me
for it and the society should pay me for
it broadly speaking and that is what is
likely to create spiritual freedom it's
this philosophy that led Nancy Pelosi to
suggest a while back that what we needed
to do was get rid of private health care
insurance because it created what she
called a job lock then it locked you
into a job you might not want to do and
she said maybe you want to be an artist
and you don't want to be an accountant
and the only reason you're an accountant
is because you get your medical
insurance from being an accountant well
if we provide to you health care then
you could go back to your room in San
Francisco you're a studio apartment in
San Francisco and be a sculptor this is
what socialism is attempting to promise
you a socialism is attempting to promise
you think we can read Jigar the economic
system so that your subjective
perception of value is no longer and
it's no longer necessary for that
subjective version of value to match up
with anybody else's version of what
value represents Hagelin says our
economy keeps its participants locked in
the realm of
for much of their lives draining away
their time and unfree activity by unfree
he means things you don't want to do now
we in the real world like to think of
things we want to do do not want to do
as responsibilities and if you want to
be happy in your job what you have to do
is actually match up three things things
that you want to do things that other
people will pay you to do and things
that you find meaningful if you can find
those three things you will be happy in
your job but one of those components is
doing something that someone else finds
valuable this is why I have described
capitalism has forced altruism and I've
described socialism as essentially
narcissism
Hagelin basically makes this clear he
says in the realm of necessity there's
very little opportunity to spend our
lives on the things we care for to
devote ourselves what we think most
worthwhile economic life may be it may
be a tapestry of choices but as long as
it directs its participants toward goals
they do not believe truly worthwhile a
life of such choices a grotesque of
freedom so this is so so Marxism in the
spiritual case focuses on two things one
there's no afterlife and no spiritual
meaning apart from your economic life
and two if your economic life is all you
have then economic freedom is you
exercising the freedom to do whatever
you want without consequences that is
the spiritual draw of Marxism and this
is why Marxism must be directed against
judeo-christian values because
judeo-christian values say listen maybe
you're not happy in your job maybe your
job isn't what provides you total
meaning every day you know it should
provide you total meaning what should
provide you total meaning is obeying the
morality of a god that matters and
making life better for those around you
and taking responsibility for your
family and broadening your and deepening
your associations with your religious
community serving God properly is the
purpose of religious life this is why
non-religious society tends to fall into
socialism because if everything that
matters is in the here and the now and
the materialistic then if this is all we
get if all we care not not even after
life wise if all that matters is our
economic performance if that's what we
see happiness as then what we really
should be doing is focusing every day on
doing what it is that we want even if it
means making mud pies and then we should
force other people to pay us for that
and if we can abstract the obligations
of other people to pass for work they
don't want to society at large if you
don't have to look at our neighbor and
say pay me five bucks
for making this crappy sculpture if
instead we can say society
makes it possible for all this to happen
if we can magically think like that if
we can think away the problem of going
broke on other people's money then
socialism sounds pretty good this is the
draw of socialism the draw of socialism
is a materialistic philosophy that
suggests that true freedom lies and not
being held to account for the decisions
that you make and not having to match up
your own subjective perceptions of value
with somebody else's ideas of value and
you know what that ends in it ends in
force because in the end if you cannot
be paid for the stupid things that you
are doing by somebody else you're going
to have to force that person to do
something that they don't want to do
every socialist system inevitably ends
in a certain level of force the more
socialism the more force and that is why
Venezuelans are eating dogs and fleeing
the country because somebody has to be
forced to pay for this bleep show okay
in just a second we'll get some things I
like and some things that I hate so
things that I like I love this so much
I love it so so so much Erick's wah whoa
this guy is one of the people running
for president and he tweeted out
yesterday and it is just quite wonderful
he tweeted out a picture of himself in
the snow in New York City and he tweeted
it's snowing in New York I need coffee
the closest cafe is inside Trump Tower
this is me walking to an alternative and
the hero music rises done took a ton
just incredible Eric's wha wha what what
you know they say that heroism is dead
70 years ago young men stormed the
beaches of Normandy at risk of their own
lives many of them died in the attempt
to free the world of Nazism and fascism
today Eric swallow walks half a block to
a different coffee shop so that he
doesn't have to participate in doing
business with an independent contractor
working inside Trump Tower
who pays rent to Donald Trump heroism is
not dead my friends not all heroes wear
capes and Eric swallow is just another
indicator that hit you today you can be
the hero we all have the hero living
inside of us and Eric's wha-whoa is
proof of that each and every day what an
amazing amazing human being Eric swallow
is and we should we should we should be
we should praise that guy we should make
that night president I mean why the helm
on it meanwhile some things that I hate
so a couple things that I hate today
Eugene Robinson has a piece over at the
Washington Post called yes the green New
Deal is audacious but we have no choice
but to think big now as I've said on
this program before I have a basic rule
if somebody says an idea is audacious
that is code word for stupid but
ambitious audacious means stupid but
ambitious it never means just ambitious
or realistic but ambitious it means
stupid and ambitious
it means unrealistic and ambitious so
you say I have an idea all the world's
people will be fed with unicorn crap
audacious idea mr. Shapiro audacious so
Eugene Robinson says that this is a very
audacious idea super audacious who's
afraid of the green new deal says Eugene
Robinson I'm not well all right its
ambitious aspirational improbable
impractical almost as audacious is
putting a man on the moon
that wasn't improbable or impractical it
was ambit it was ambitious and
aspirational you know how we know that
it wasn't impractical cuz we did it with
like a slide rule we used to be able to
think big let's do it again
I love this idea that thinking big is
self-justifying I had a big idea today I
decided to run in front of a truck it
was a big idea it was very important to
my life a life-changing idea you might
say I decided I was gonna run in front
of a moving truck thinking big you two
can think big in America since the 14
page resolution was introduced in
Congress last week by Senator Ed Markey
and representative aoc so fresh so face
critics have been following over
themselves to denounce the green New
Deal's policies as prohibitively
expensive totally unworkable or somehow
Venezuelan if these opponents would stop
shouting long enough to actually read
the document they'd see that it's not a
compendium of concrete policies at all
but rather a set of goals yeah I've read
it and the goals are unrealistic and
quite stupid because when you propose
things that are utterly unrealistic like
let's harness the power of the Sun and
if we harness the power of the Sun then
we can power everybody's life at an
income level twice what we normally do
it what are you talking about what are
you talking about if we can find an
alien source of energy that provides us
cold fusion then we can fix the world
thinking big audacious a set of goals he
says they are the wrinkles the green new
zeal seeks to outline a national project
for our time not just a response so a
grave environmental threat but
framework for enhanced growth
opportunity and fairness the laudable
aim is to play offense not defense I
mean it's like the guy just stacked up
cliches in the movie Bull Durham which I
have famously said it's an overrated
film but in the movie Bull Durham
there's great scene where Kevin Costner
is trying to inform Tim Robbins about
how exactly he needs to act when he gets
to the major leagues in his interviews
he needs to just spit cliches you know
we take it one day at a time I'm doing
my best out there the team comes first
that is this column except with
environmentalism the water will image to
play offense not defense in the fight to
limit climate change
well aren't you inevitably playing
defense when you are fighting against an
encroaching looming disaster he says we
are going to have to wage that bad on
one way or another why not do it on our
terms before Miami slips under water and
the unburned parts of California go up
in flames I love this idea that Miami is
gonna be underwater like in the next two
years does it occur to people that over
time human beings are massively capable
of that app tation that if you give
somebody a hundred years and you tell
them by the way your house is gonna be
underwater in a hundred years what are
you going to do about it then maybe they
might start making gradual plans to move
away from the house that will be
underwater in 100 years the best
historical analogy I love this one the
best historical analogy is not the New
Deal but world war two don't stop Bluto
he's already rolling guys when
mobilization of the nation's vast
productive capacity not only defeated
Germany and Japan but also generated
unprecedented domestic economic growth
hugely expanding middle class World War
two did not generate unprecedented
domestic economic growth after World War
Two is when the economic growth happens
when you mobilize every military-age
male put them in barracks and feed them
rations for four years it turns out that
that is not economic growth war does not
create economic growth is a basic
economic fallacy if war created economic
growth then we would be involved in
massive wars all the time we are not
believe it or not even Afghanistan and
Iraq we're not massive Wars by any
serious measure once again says Eugene
Robinson the planet faces a dire threat
once again the United States can help
lead the world to victory okay well I
have a proposal I have a proposal you
know it's actually easier than getting
rid of all carbon fuels and airplanes
you know it's actually easier than
slaughtering all the farting cows we
should invade China and India we should
invade China in India because the United
States is the world's number one reducer
of carbon emissions you know who
continues
to ramp up their emissions India and
China so if you want to liken this to
World War two man let's do this thing
you want to liken this to World War two
say this is an emergency so grave that
we have to mobilize the entire American
population guess what we could bring our
carbon emissions down to zero down to
zero and you know what that would do to
the global climate according to the IPCC
and we lower it by something like 0.15
degrees Celsius over the course of the
next century in other words it would do
nearly nothing you know we would need to
do we need to bomb all the coal-fired
plants in India and China so let's do
this thing
I want to see sufficient commitment from
the left because I mean after all this
is a world-changing thing we're talking
about here right I mean this is
something that we have to stop right now
in its tracks we don't have time it's an
emergency
well it's an emergency and if all of us
throwing away our cars wouldn't actually
stop climate change and if it really is
an emergency if this is the day after
tomorrow we're all gonna die if that's
the case then why what are you waiting
for the real offenders here are China in
India and I think it's time that we
discussed that's what the millet all
options are on the table you guys are
talking about World War two not me
you're saying this is like World War two
you know what we did in World War two we
bombed the living bleep out of pretty
much everybody who's really ugly we
saved the world from Nazism so if we
have to if we're gonna treat this like
it's Nazism then why not let's show you
show your commitment left show your
commitment let's invade China in India
let's do this thing come on let's do it
for the environment let's do it from the
panda bears let's do this to make sure
that the permafrost up in Alaska staves
permanently stays permanently frosted
let's do this I love this it's too
expensive naysayers complains as Eugene
Robinson they point to a clause in the
resolution that calls for upgrading all
existing buildings in the United States
to make them more energy-efficient
that sounds absurd until you remember
the massive blackout drills that took
place across the country during World
War two people participated it was their
patriotic duty you know it's harder
actually than like turning off your
lights for an hour every night
retrofitting or tearing down every
building in the United States it's and
this is the best part he says acting
alone would be pointless skeptics say no
not skeptics the IPCC not skeptic
people who believe in all this stuff
indeed China is by now the by far the
world's biggest carbon emitter with the
United States second in India a
fast-rising third what would be the
point of going to great efforts to
reduce US emissions while others just
burn more coal think about it though we
are after all whenever people say think
about it always a good indicator that
what comes next is really dumb it's you
know you say that you should not
actually eat that ceramic jar you say
you shouldn't eat it but think about it
think about my proposal just just take a
second I want you to think think about
it we are after all the second biggest
emitter which means that any substantial
reduction would indeed have measurable
impact it is measurable I just told you
what the measurement is 0.18 five
degrees Celsius over the next century
now you give me your stat because mine
came from the IPCC you don't also
officials in China in India unlike those
in the Trump administration understand
and accept the conclusions of climate
scientists what okay if you say that you
understand and accept the conclusions of
climate scientists then you're like you
know what else I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna burn this coal right here like
right over here like right next to me
I've got a pile of coal I just set it on
fire man but I accept the conclusions of
climate scientists that makes me better
than you you don't accept all the
conclusions of the clients and climate
scientists but you're not emitting you
know what makes me better than you I
accept those conclusions now watch I'm
gonna like this pile of coal on fire
China may be adding coal-fired power
plants but it is also making massive
investments in clean energy do you
really want Beijing to lead the way in
the future
shouldn't it be Washington oh man the
cliches they may be adding coal-fired
power plants but they're making massive
investments in clean energy you know why
cuz they're a communist country they can
afford to do both by starving their own
citizens it's fine also the first half
of the sentence would be the one that
matters they are adding coal-fired power
plants if you invest in a lot of green
energy but at the same time you are
investing in the carbon emitting coal
plants you are part of the prep aisle of
this he's justifying China so he can
claim that the United States ought to
shut down all carbon emissions which
would have virtually no measurable
impact on the climate over the next
century
again I returns my initial assessment
Eugene Robinson is not sufficiently
committed to stopping climate change and
neither is anyone else
for the green new deal if they were
truly committed if they really believe
that this is a world-beating World War 2
problem it's time we have to invade
China in India we have no choice the
world is warming the earth has a favour
and it's time for us to do something
about it alright so a little bit later
on we have two more hours of Ben Shapiro
show goodness coming up but you got to
be a daily Y remember go check it out
right now become a subscriber so much
goodness I didn't get to get to in
today's show go check that out we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Adam sy Yvette's audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Joshua alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19